ja ich schon so auch unser alter papst
benedikt erlebt eine mittelschwere image
krise sowie die katholische kirche
insgesamt schon wieder
missbrauchsskandal und kein ende seit
gestern tag der so genannte synodale weg
da diskutieren zu gleichen teilen klerus
und laien also die parteien die noch
glauben ihre kirche könnte eines tages
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
ankommen der synodale weg steht für die
hoffnung auf reformen und da hat sich
der regensburger bischof order holzer
gedacht kommen für die stimmung im saal
zitiere ich doch einfach mal was
angeblich in den siebzigern in sachen
missbrauch so forschungsstand war
nämlich dass das
für die betroffenen kinder und
jugendlichen die
vernehmungen wesentlich schlimmer sind
als die im grunde harmlose
missbrauchsfälle
hui
selbst wenn man da hinterher behauptet
nur irgendwelchen blödsinn zitiert zu
haben kein guter einstieg in seine
reform veranstaltung ein neues gutachten
für das bistum münchen zeigt gerade
einmal mehr wie die kirche über
jahrzehnte systematisch ihre täter
geschützt hat ist der laden überhaupt
reformierbar wobei gehört auch zu weit
an der basis arbeiten schon noch ein
paar gute leute leute die verstanden
haben so wie dieses kölsche priester
original während die kirche ein
weltlicher konzern wären sie jetzt
pleite natürlich sind eine gurkentruppe
wie man in köln sagt ja sicher
gurkentruppe passt in diesem
zusammenhang leider doppelt jetzt hängt
also unser papst auch noch mit drin man
das gutachten bescheinigt ihm
fehlverhalten in gleich mehreren
vertuschungs fällen und dann hat
benedikt in seiner ersten stellungnahme
auch noch die unwahrheit gesagt
er war in einer entscheidenden sitzung
damals eben doch dabei als es um peter h
gegen einen pädophilen priester aus
essen der in ratzingers bistum geparkt
wurde war aber keine flügel sagt seinen
sekretär sondern
die folge eines versehens bei der
redaktionellen bearbeitung
heißt entweder hat benedikt einen fehler
gemacht oder er hat doch gelogen so oder
so ist damit plötzlich quasi
wissenschaftlich bewiesen
der park ist gar nicht viel
was kommt als nächstes raus der papst
boxt gar nicht im kettenhemd man ist
fassungslos was ich persönlich aber viel
schlimmer finde er hat in seiner ersten
stellungnahme nicht mal moralische
verantwortung übernommen für das was
damals in seinem bistum münchen passiert
ist stattdessen versteckt er sich hinter
muss man so sagen kirchenrechtlichen
details und und blamiert sich bis auf
die knochen
der emeritierte papst schreibt etwa über
einen strafrechtlich verurteilten
priester der von mädchen masturbiert
haben soll pfarrer punkt punkt punkt ist
als exhibitionist aufgefallen aber nicht
als missbrauchs-täter im eigentlichen
sinn ach so na dann
wenigstens hat er nichts von der hand
gottes geschrieben magen gott wer berät
den man wirklich und nochmal zur
klarstellung dass systematische
verstecken und versetzen von leuten wie
dem [ __ ] peter h hat natürlich noch
mehr kinder in gefahr gebracht das ist
beihilfe zum missbrauch aber na ja das
sind halt so die feinheiten des
kirchenrechts und der kirchlichen moral
das sieht man ja schon auf
mittelalterlichen gemälden ein fahrer
der sich zu lebzeiten gerne sagen wir
mal gezeigt hat kommt trotzdem in den
himmel und unten in der hölle schmoren
derweil die geschiedene die es gewagt
haben noch mal zu heiraten diese kranken
perversling
nach jedem neuen enthüllungs gutachten
die immer gleichen lehrern demos gesten
der deutschen bischöfe die aber nie
zurücktreten achten sie mal darauf nie
warum eigentlich nicht selbst ein ex
papst könnte doch die weiße kappe
einfach an die garderobe hängen statt
immer nur zu sagen wie jetzt ich bete
für die opfer rückt man lieber die
personalakten aus euren geheimen
archiven raus endlich in deutschland und
dafür muss man sich wirklich stehen in
deutschland hat es noch nie eine
staatsanwaltschaftliche durchsuchung in
irgendeiner kirchenverwaltung gegeben
noch
über jahrzehnte hat man der kirche
erlaubt beim thema missbrauch gegen sich
selber zu ermitteln wie wäre das wohl
wenn der staat andere delikte oder
andere kriminelle auch so verfolgen
würde wie die katholische kirche wenn
die polizei einen drogendealer auf
frischer tat mit koks erwischt dann käme
der nicht mehr vor ein normales gericht
sondern vor ein internes gericht des
deutschen drogendealer verbands das tag
immer auf dem parkplatz hinterm bahnhof
da sagt man dann als angeklagter demütig
klingende sachen wie
leute ich bin natürlich erschüttert ich
bete für meine opfer und dann sagt der
vorsitzende des dealer gerichts weiter
es muss konsequenzen haben und dann wird
man zur strafe eine andere straßenecke
zum dealen versetzt direkt neben dem
spielplatz
junge was
ja das würde ich meine lehre sein kein
wunder dass immer mehr leute dieser
kirche im moment den rücken kehren ist
ja so in manchen städten wartet man ewig
auf seinen austrittstermin beim haben
das kann monate dauern und was viele gar
nicht wissen also wirklich nur als total
unverbindlicher tipp fürs austreten
reicht tatsächlich eine schriftliche
erklärung die sie dann nur noch vom
notar beglaubigen lassen hier auf
unserem heute schon notar rennen sie die
bude ein einfach unterschreiben
beglaubigen lassen beim amtsgericht in
den briefkasten schmeißen sagt
ausgetreten ohne termin ja
viel einfacher als beim handy vertrag
wie gesagt ich will da gar kein drängen
nur falls sie sowas interessiert so wie
geht es weiter für die kirche reden wir
darüber mit unserem heute-show
moraltheologen mit olaf schubert hallo
schön dass du da bist olaf der münchner
kardinal marx hat diese woche
vorgeschlagen achtung das zölibat
abzuschaffen er sagt für manche priester
wäre es besser sie werden verheiratet
wie siehst du das
kühne these ich meine ich bin ja
überzeugter marxist aber die lösung ist
glaube ich nicht in meiner es mag jetzt
priester geben die von den träumen aber
ich bin ja verheiratet ich träume
wiederum vom zölibat und die ehe ist
deshalb nicht lösung ganz klar ich meine
geht ja erst ab 8 und 18 sind die
meisten probanden ja dann für die presse
schon wieder nicht mehr attraktiv also
warum gleich heiraten also ich denke die
priester müssen hier erst mal
erfahrungen sammeln so drehten erst mal
also
kinder statt kinder ja das wäre ein
schritt in die richtige richtung um sich
dort anzumelden muss man volljährig zu
sein zum üben quasi in deutschland gönnt
man der kirche sogar ein eigenes
arbeitsrecht die können zb ihre
mitarbeiter die sich outen feuern oder
eben wiederverheiratete geschiedene ist
diese kirche so wie sie ist überhaupt
modernisiert was glaubst du ich denke
die kirche will ist sie versucht es ja
sie hat ja nicht umsonst wirklich vieles
in den nachwuchs gesteckt aber
lohnt ist das ist ja die frage ja ich
meine die kirche ist er wie so eine
antiquität also nur im originalzustand
wertvoll also man kann da irgendwas
machen aber was nutzt es ich meine wenn
du den toten hamster irgendwie neu
lackiert
sicherlich irgendwie schicker aus aber
er wird dadurch nicht auferstehen und
ich glaube die menschen wie ich also wir
leben doch gerade dieses gelebte
mittelalter dieses ganze bohei diese
seltsamen hüte das monat diese trachten
der bayer auch alles grün ja das ist
auch irgendwie las vegas in mal richtig
und wohin modernisierung führt das sehen
wir bei den evangelen oder nüchterne
kahle klinker wende also ich glaube das
zieht seltsame leute an
da kommt dann dr eckart von hirschhausen
um die ecke und sinken die zu
holzgitarre das ist nicht zielführend
also kirche modernisieren nur aus
energetischen gründen ja also durch
diese großen fenster zieht ganz schön
rein also zumindest christliche leyen
fordern ja seit jahren endlich frauen im
priesteramt warum zum teufel sperrt sich
rom da so was glaubst du warum
ich glaube ich seiner verantwortung
bewusst ja die kirche ist ja im prinzip
eine der letzten bastion gegen den
grassierenden krimis muss terra also da
gibt es diese achsen macht rom iran
kabul ja ja und natürlich
fremde die kirche mit der frau im amt
man müsste sich das sanft annähern ja
also vielleicht erstmal über eine neue
binäre personen über über einen transfer
also dann eben jetzt nicht gleich
priesterin man könnte das war ein ein
junior priester so irgendwie bald
bestelle plus in einer ganz kleinen
kirche wird die hälfte des geldes denn
die grundschuld nicht natürlich schon
beim bei biasi ist einfach moralisch
nicht so rein wie der mann sie hat viel
porzellan zerschlagen klaren weil ich
meine wer hat denn den apfel gebissen ne
das war die fa
josef hatte maria vertraut und dann hat
sie ihn betrogen und rumgemacht mit dem
heiligen geist der war so enttäuscht
also ja ich glaube es ist an der frau
das verlorene vertrauen zurückgewinnen
müssen zu also das kann zwei dreitausend
jahre dauern das ist ganz normal
wahrscheinlich olaf schubert
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leichter last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da